el carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
bienvenidos una vez más a este espacio
donde exploramos la rica actualidad
cultural francesa hoy carrusel os invita
a un paseo por el mundo de la fotografía
la literatura las series y la música
comenzamos ya mismo
[Música]
conoceremos a la fotógrafa venezolana
ana maría arévalo premiada en francia
por sus fotos reportajes días eternos un
crudo relato sobre las condiciones de
vida de las mujeres en centros de
detención les contaremos una relación
que se perdió en los meandros de la
historia el intenso amor que unió al
poeta jack baudelaire y su musa negra
llamada llana damos una mirada a la
serie ganadora del emmy la francesa tipo
son una comedia inteligente y sarcástica
que ha hecho reír en todo el mundo y en
este programa una vuelta a los años 20
les dan y folk de la mano del sexteto de
jazz parisino jacques and hills
[Música]
abrimos este carrusel dando una mirada
al trabajo de la venezolana ana maría
arévalo ella es fotógrafa y milita por
los derechos de las mujeres fue premiada
en francia por una serie impactante
sobre las condiciones de vida en los
centros de detención preventiva y
nosotros la conocimos en el festival
visa pour l'image de perpiñán
[Música]
la fotógrafa venezolana maría arévalo
plasmó en imágenes algo que muy pocos
pueden o quieren ver las terribles
condiciones de vida de las mujeres
privadas de libertad se trata de un
fotorreportaje impactante bajo el título
días eternos imágenes que revelan el
nivel de abandono estatal en los centros
de detención
buenos días eternos es un proyecto que
comencé en el 2017 en venezuela sobre
las condiciones deplorables de las
mujeres en centros de detención
preventiva y cárceles de venezuela este
año enero pasé tres meses en el salvador
también profundizando un poco sobre el
proceso de reinserción positiva o
negativa de estas mujeres ya que también
trabajé fuera de la cárcel
arévalo pudo acceder a estos centros
entrevistar a decenas de mujeres y
componer un relato visual que deja claro
las carencias y numerosas violaciones a
los derechos humanos que padecen las
mujeres en detención las mujeres no
tienen ningún tipo de servicios médicos
no tienen ayuda psicológica no tienen
espacio no tienen actividad no tienen
luz natural en algunos sitios entonces
desde la primera vez que yo llegué a
este centro de atención yo dije nada
este es el trabajo que yo voy a hacer
son todas las personas que yo fotografía
ninguna viene de clase media de clase
alto las personas normales que están en
la cárcel sin sin ser políticos son
personas muy pobres
lo que más me impresiona es el todo de
una situación tan terrible y tan
infrahumana y tan triste un preso en
venezuela necesita o en el salvador
necesita del apoyo de la familia para
poder sobrevivir esta experiencia no
para de sobrevivir esta espera eterna de
que se supone que son 45 días en
detención preventiva pero que obviamente
a causa de la crisis eso es mentira eso
puede durar meses o años incluso que
realmente no se está hablando de esto y
que la situación es muy muy grave
la serie de días eternos soy distinguida
en la ciudad de perpiñán con el premio
camilo pai ha creado en honor a una
fotógrafa francesa asesinada en
república centroafricana en 2014
que mi trabajo puede llegar a una
audiencia más amplia es genial y además
yo admiro
el trabajo que hizo camino y admiro
además también a su madre que tiene este
compromiso con nosotros los
fotoperiodistas
entonces nada es muy importante para mí
estoy muy contenta y ahora mi plan es
continuarlo en el resto de latinoamérica
[Música]
y a continuación los invitamos a
descubrir una faceta poco conocida de
jacques baudelaire el célebre poeta
francés del siglo 19 en épocas en que la
esclavitud seguía vigente el autor de
las flores del mal' vivió una historia
de amor con una mujer negra en parís les
contamos este prolífico romance de la
mano de melissa barra
ah
quién fue jan la misteriosa musa de
cabello rizado y piel morena que inspiró
algunos poemas de baudelaire un escritor
y un historietista desempolvaron la vida
del poeta francés para contar su
relación con esta enigmática mujer cuyos
orígenes y apellidos reales se
desconocen rafael confió es autor de un
libro sobre ella
cuando se estudia baudelaire nos dicen
que hubo una mujer llamada jean oriunda
de las islas pero sin entrar en detalles
quise volver la visible contar el papel
que desempeñó durante los 15 años que
estuvo junto a uno de los mayores poetas
del siglo 19 no fue una cazafortunas
tampoco fue su concubino ni su objeto
exótico fue mucho más que todo eso sin
ella puede leer nunca se hubiese
convertido en el gran poeta que fue
poder conoció a jean en una obra de
teatro cuando tenía 20 años
tiene un momento de la obra apareció una
mujer negra altísima pronuncia una sola
frase con un acento fuerte dice lo la
comida está servida señora ahí toda la
sala soltó una carcajada y el único que
no vio fue poder unos meses después hubo
una pelea callejera en frente de una
taberna de parís dos hombres le estaban
dando una golpiza a una mujer al
ahuyentar los se dio cuenta de que era
la mujer de la obra de teatro y
así comenzó una larga y tumultuosa
relación en una época en la que la
esclavitud era legal en las colonias
francesas bootleg se paseaba por las
calles parisinas con la que llamó su
venus negra
palabrita disfrute en la calle la
insultaba a baudelaire lo insultaban
lanzaban gritos de cine a ella no le
importaba esta mujer era libre
frecuentaba los cafés bebía absenta
hablaba fuerte y eran muy alta que el
estadio al fútbol bootleg le dedica
hayan varios poemas de su célebre las
flores del mal como la cabellera las
joyas o la serpiente que danza
volver a
baudelaire solía inventar sus poemas
verbalmente ya no anotaba ciertos versos
escribía ciertas metáforas que el poeta
pronunciaba días después le entregaba un
papel diciéndole esto fue lo que creaste
tenía pues un rol de escriba o sea un
rol que no era secundario hay una
presencia femenina de transfondo que es
una inspiración constante
incluso cuando se peleaban o se separaba
ella representaba un mundo que rompía
los códigos que le fueron inculcados a
baudelaire incluso en sociedades
relacionadas como las de hoy no es fácil
vivir como una pareja mixta
imagínense como era en el siglo 19 antes
de que abrieran la esclavitud por dicen
evidencia claro a la policía
la musa tenebrosa de salvo de ley es un
relato de rafael cumplió y mademoiselle
bootleg es una historieta del belga islr
[Música]
y las series francesas siguen triunfando
de epoc son llama a mi agente fue
galardonada con un premio emmy esta
serie cuenta las vicisitudes de una
agencia de actores de cine en pleno país
nos lo cuenta lucía valentín
[Música]
y pakistán rivas
llama a mi agente en su versión en
español cuenta con mucho humor el día a
día de una prestigiosa agencia parisina
de representación de actores esta serie
ganadora del emmy internacional a la
mejor serie de drama cuenta con cuatro
temporadas y un total de 24 episodios el
público descubre el mundillo del cine
desde el seno de esta agencia donde se
negocian contratos y se lidia con los
caprichos y susceptibilidades de cada
actor el punto fuerte de difusión es que
en cada capítulo aparece una estrella
del cine francés interpretándose a sí
misma como charlotte gainsbourg
[Música]
lanzada en 2015 por fans televisión
difusión ha causado sensación fuera de
francia tras su llegada a la plataforma
netflix y se espera que unos 20 remakes
de la serie sean filmados en todo el
mundo
[Música]
y pasamos ya mismo a nuestra crónica
musical con una tal olivares hola
natalia hola maría carolina bueno y en
cada ocasión nos presenta un artista de
la escena musical francesa esta vez es
un sexteto que vamos a descubrir ya
mismo
no
y desde las alturas del distrito 15 de
parís les presentamos al sexteto de jazz
swing se llama jack en jeans y nos
presentan su nuevo disco charly de edad
[Música]
me llamo yo plan podemos hoy con trabajo
de los rangers
ya que en chile es el nombre de una
competencia de danza de swing donde los
que participan no se conocen entre ellos
ya que se sortean y el desafío es tener
éxito bailando en pareja sin
necesariamente conocerse
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el objetivo era ese tocar para que la
gente baile swing dijo y charleston esto
es realmente el adn del proyecto y nos
quedamos en esa línea
aquí
[Música]
llegamos a los años 2030 a los default
los años locos con esos bailes como el
charlestón el lindy hop y en este álbum
soul y the dog el sexteto habla de una
canción que se llama all the cat join in
y es una canción que explica bastante
bien quiénes son ellos
los cats es el apodo de los jazz man en
eeuu y la canción all the caption in
hace referencia a eso al hecho de
reunirse entre gatos para tocar música
y un poco como gatos callejeros una
referencia a los aristogatos
personalmente me encantó esa película de
pequeño así que sí es una clara
referencia a un pequeño guiño nuestro de
ancash
[Música]
los giants y los ya que giles
promocionan su álbum sólido con
bailarines profesionales pero también en
las calles de parís para que familias
enteras puedan mover el esqueleto al
ritmo del swing bueno muchísimas gracias
natale olivares por habernos presentado
este sexteto y justamente vamos a
terminar nuestro programa con un tema de
los jack and jill all the cats join in
muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros y hasta la próxima
[Música]
wayne usted
d
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí
no
yo
[Música]
[Música]
i
no no
bueno
[Música]
yo
por eso
entiendo
[Música]
por qué
d
[Música]
y yo
el tubo